sie ist die erste autoren die
milliardärin geworden ist
es gibt nicht viele autoren die habe ich
in serie heraus bringt die sich alle am
ersten tag 12 15 millionen mal verkaufen
ihre vorstellungskraft hat kinder und
erwachsene begeistert und jede branche
verändert die sie berührte harry potter
selbst war so groß wie ein kleiner
verlage
harry potter ist das maß aller dinge es
ist das größte film franchises aller
zeiten
rowlings märchenhafte erfolg wurde aus
überlebenskampf und herzschmerz geboren
sich für arbeitslos und alleinerziehend
ich war die grösste versagerin die ich
kannte
mit einem ende wie aus dem bilderbuch
[Musik]
im mittelpunkt der finanziell
erfolgreichsten erzählungen der
geschichte der belletristik harry potter
steht die einzigartige und entschlossene
joanne rowling
sie verkaufte um die 400 millionen
exemplare den vereinigten staaten und
brachte eine milliarde kinder dazu
45 600 seitige welt zu lesen und das in
einer zeit in der kinder überhaupt keine
büchern lasen
wohl über zehn milliarden dollar an
gesamteinnahmen ist das ein absolut
erstaunliches franchise dass wir meiner
meinung nach nie wieder sehen werden die
popularität von harry potter hat rowling
in die ungewohnte welt der berühmtheit
katapultiert nachdem sie einst von
paparazzi gejagt wurde schränkt sie
heute den zugang zu ihrem privatleben
ein und lehnte es ab an dieser
dokumentation mitzuwirken
rowling wurde 1965 in klassischer
england geboren schauspieler jim dale
der von rohlinger ist sprecher für die
harry potter hörbücher in den
vereinigten staaten ausgewählt wurde
kannte diese ländlichen dörfern gut
diesen kleinen städten lebten keine
reichen menschen alle gehörten zur
arbeiterklasse mann gingen die häuser
und sah die selbe tapete die man selbst
hatte denn es gab nur ein einziges
tapeten geschäft in der stadt es gab nur
einen genossenschafts laden und so sah
man dass das gleiche kleid das die
eigene mutter trug auch von zwei oder
drei anderen frauen getragen wurde das
ist also die art von umgebung rowlings
literarische ambitionen wurden schon
früh erkannt ihr erstes buch mit dem
titel haase stellte sie mit sechs jahren
fertigt villis ein alley interviewte
rowling für ihr buch harry eine
geschichte voller magie
es ging um ein kaninchen das krank wird
und bei all seinen anderen hasen und als
es fertig hatte brachte sie es
anscheinend ihrer mutter und sagte nun
veröffentliche es wird daraus jetzt etwa
einiges gemacht
doch hinter dem selbstvertrauen verbarg
sich unsicherheit wie rolling bei opa
gestammt ich bin kein mensch mit viel
selbstbewusstsein ich war niemand mit
besonders viel von irgendwas ich würde
sogar sagen ich war jemand mit wenig
selbstvertrauen und doch glaubte ich an
diese eine sache in meinem leben das war
die eine sache immer im leben ich fühlte
dass ich eine geschichte erzählen kann
ihre geschichte wurde in kassel einem
kleinen dorf in der grafschaft
gloucestershire geschrieben tanja
ceccacci an arbeitete als produzentin
bei den ersten vier harry potter filmen
eng mit rolling zusammen hatte sowohl
einen mikroskopischen als auch einen
mikrokosmos im blick auf hogwarts im
harry potter universum
sie war im westen des landes
aufgewachsen in der nähe des waldes von
dienen wo auch ich einen großteil meiner
kindheit verbracht hatte wir hatten also
eine menge gemeinsamer bezugspunkt
alles vorüber jay kay in ihren büchern
schreibt findet sich irgendwo in england
wieder das muss so sein wir haben die
fantastischen alten schlösser passen sie
haben diese wunderbaren alten gebäude
wir haben diese wälder die man anhand
ihrer beschreibung selbst kennt oder
dort in der nähe finden kann wo sie
einst gelebt hat
1980 wurde bei ihrer mutter multiple
sklerose diagnostiziert ein tragisches
ereignis für die familie doch das hielt
rowling nicht davon ab an ihrer
leidenschaft für die belletristik weiter
festzuhalten weder in der schule noch
später am college so hat in exeter
classic studiert da kommt alles her ihre
klassische bildung findet sich in den
harry potter büchern wieder die
griechischen mythen die christlichen
allegorien
nach dem college bezahlte rowling ihre
miete indem sie bei amnesty
international in london arbeitete wo sie
in ihrer mittagspause geschichten
schrieb
wenn uns in 190 hat sie dann in einem
zug nach london eine idee die ihr leben
verändern sollte
blieb stehen und ihr kam buchstäblich in
den kopf zauberer junge der nicht weiß
dass er ein zauberer ist geht auf eine
zauberer schule und weil sie keinen
stift hatte saß sie stundenlang da und
dachte nach während der zug weiter da
stand sie fing damit an der schule einen
namen zu geben sich gedanken über die
lehrer zu machen die in harry potter und
ich erklärt sie was das für ein lebens
verändernder moment gewesen ist
dieses unglaubliche kribbeln das man
bekommt wenn man gerade jemanden
kennengelernt hat in dem man sich
vielleicht verlieben wird die ganze
harry weltweit ihre leidenschaft das
ausmaß in dem dieser enzyklopädische
lebendige verstand wusste was hinter
einer tür sein würde von der man auch
nicht einmal wusste das war wirklich
erstaunlich
nur sechs monate später erhielt sie eine
herzzerreißende nachricht
ihre mutter war an multipler sklerose
verstorben rowling sprach mit der bbc
über ihren verlust
habe sechs monate vor ihrem tod mit dem
schreiben von harry begonnen das ist das
ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich weil ich
ihn nie gesagt habe dass ich überhaupt
schreiber sie hat also nie etwas von
harry potter erfahren
der tod von jobs mutter hat sich auf ihr
gesamtes schreiben ausgewirkt auf jede
einzelne seite von harry potter er hat
ihre ansichten von liebe und tod
verändert und davon was es bedeutet wenn
uns jemand verlässt und welche
auswirkungen das auf unser leben hat sie
konzentrierte sich zunehmend auf den
zauberjungen und wurde schließlich von
mehreren jobs gefeuert weil sie schrieb
anstatt zu arbeiten das war eine dunkle
zeit für die arbeitslose autorin rowling
beschloss england ganz zu verlassen
joanne rowling verließ england um in
porto portugal einen neuanfang zu machen
sie bekam einen job als lehrerin und
schrieb nebenher weiter
rowling heiratet einen lokalen
fernsehjournalisten und bekam innerhalb
eines jahres eine tochter aber nach
einer wie sie es nannte kurzen und
katastrophalen er zog sie nach edinburgh
schottland um in der nähe ihrer
schwester zu sein
ich glaube sie fühlte sich ein bisschen
als versagerin weil sie arm war weil sie
sehr gut ausgebildet war aber bisher
einfach keine karriere gemacht hatte
obwohl versuchte einen job als lehrerin
zu bekommen aber die arbeit war nicht
beständig und so musste sie öffentliche
hilfe in anspruch nehmen sie lebte von
der hand in den mund von tag zu tag in
absoluter armut am existenzminimum
es ist nicht lange und nicht romantisch
aber es hat dazu beigetragen dass dieses
buch letztendlich in produktion ging
rowling sagte dass der tiefpunkt die
grundlage für den wiederaufbau ihres
lebens war
die schrieb in der wärme eines cafés
weiter während ihre tochter neben ihr
schlief
und als sie die ersten drei kapitel hat
vor mit denen sie zufrieden war schickte
sie sie an einen agenten
es wurde abgelehnt
1995 schickte sie drei kapitel an die
agentur von chris liddell dort wurde es
genauso behandelt wie es für werke
unbekannter autoren üblich war die
little in sechs erzählte
diese dinge können ewig auf einem stapel
liegen man nennt ihn auch den matsch
laufen aber wie ist der zufall wollte
nahm ich zwei tage später diesen stapel
in die hand und nahm ihn mit zum
mittagessen wenn meine begleitung spät
dran war und drinnen begann ich von
harry potter zu lesen und wir stellten
sich die nackenhaare auf aber zwölf
verleger lehnten das buch ab
niemand wollte weil es damals politisch
unkorrekt war internate zu bewerben es
war zwei mal so lang wie ein kinderbuch
sein durfte es hatte diesen ellenlangen
titel harry potter und der stein der
weisen es war genau das was verleger
damals nicht an büchern haben wollten
und so brachte er es nicht an den mann
das buch fand schließlich seinen weg zu
einem neuen kinderbuchverlag namens
bloomsbury
potter bibb ist medienanalyst und die
ehemalige verleger
die tochter des geschäftsführers hat die
ersten beiden kapitel gelesen ging sie
am tat und sagte sie wollen mehr davon
lesen es ist eben auch das schöne am
verlagswesen los geht zu einem großen
teil ums bauchgefühl
[Musik]
1996 sechs jahre nach dem rohling mit
dem schreiben von harry potter begonnen
hatte bot bloomsbury 4000 dollar für das
buch an das war nicht viel aber für
rowling war es magisch magic der moment
in dem er mir sagte dass bloomsbury das
buch übernehmen wollte war nach der
geburt meiner tochter der glücklichste
moment meines lebens
aber es gab einen haken um die
marktfähigkeit zu verbessern wollte
bloomsbury dass sie ihren namen in etwas
geschlechtsneutral es ändert wie little
in sexy - erklärte
traditionell lesen jungs nicht gerne
bücher die von mädchen geschrieben
wurden mädchen ist es egal wer die
bücher geschrieben als aber jungs haben
diese seltsame sexistische einstellung
joanne lieh sich von ihrer großmutter
kathleen eine mittlere initiale und
wurde jay kay rowling
auf der buchmesse in bologna 1997 sprach
sich das buch schnell herum raffaele
wien vizepräsident von sco lästig war
dorthin geflogen um nach etwas
besonderem zu suchen
ich wollte bücher finden die nicht nur
im trend liegen oder gerade populär sind
sondern die von den kindern wirklich
geliebt und ihre lieblingsbücher werden
michael jacobs war zu diesem zeitpunkt
zehn jahre weiß präsident der
handelsabteilung von sco lästig
es war sicherlich ein buch das in
bologna viel aufsehen erregt hat und ich
glaube für aber war als ziemlich
offensichtlich dass das buch das
potenzial für eine serie hatte aber das
erste buch war schon an und für sich
außergewöhnlich stellen
bot eine beispiellose summe von 105.000
dollar für die amerikanischen rechte
hand im ersten harry potter buch als sie
den anruf von christopher little erhielt
der ihr sagte dass ihr buch für 100 5000
dollar nach amerika verkauft wurde sagte
sie dass sie zum ersten mal sehr
erschrocken war es war einfach
überwältigend um ehrlich zu sein hatte
mich das leben in den letzten jahren so
sehr gebeutelt dass ich ziemlich
misstrauisch war wenn ich gute
nachrichten erhielt die guten
nachrichten wurden mehr 1997 wurde das
buch in großbritannien veröffentlicht
und wurde zum erfolg
die erste generation der schulhof potter
fans war geboren
joanne rowling zweites buch war bereits
in arbeit nachdem der erste harry potter
zu einem spitzenpreis als günstig
verkauft worden war sie spürte einen
enormen druck den schwung beizubehalten
der verkauf nach amerika war in england
eine große sache ist eine unbekannte
britische autorin verkauft ihr erstes
buch auf dem amerikanischen markt der im
gegensatz zum englischen markt fünf oder
sechsmal so groß ist es war wie die
geschichte vom tellerwäscher eine arme
autorin wurde zum millionär in die
amerikanischen verleger hofften dass
harry potter abliefern würde
wir wussten dass wir etwas besonderes in
den händen hielten und das wussten wir
schon ziemlich früh unser ansatz war
also wirklich es wie einen blockbuster
zu veröffentlichen
[Applaus]
lästig eine art spezialeinsatzkommando
dass sich jede woche wegen harry potter
traf skuletic entschied sich für einen
interaktiven ansatz zur vermarktung des
buches the trading wir haben das buch
einigen auserwählten vor
veröffentlichung zum lesen gegeben ich
glaube einige von ihnen haben rolling
sogar treffen dürfen bevor das buch
überhaupt veröffentlicht wurde auf diese
weise haben wir also einen riesen wirbel
ausgelöst und als das buch dann in den
verkauf ging verbreitete es sich wie ein
lauffeuer
harry potter und der stein der weisen
verkaufte sich in zehn monaten über
800.000 mal und stand über ein jahr lang
auf der bestsellerliste der new york
times
als der zweite teil 1999 in den usa die
läden kam wurde die veröffentlichung der
potter bücher zu einem großen ereignis
so lästig zog die öffentlichkeit in
seinen bann
extra sie veranstalteten zu jedem neuen
titel der heraus kam ein spektakel
seitdem buchstäblich tausende von
kindern vor den buchläden standen meist
in kostümen mitten in der nacht um ein
exemplar abzubekommen sexy logistik an
einem tag zehn oder elf millionen
exemplare eines buches auf den markt zu
bringen war schwierig wie sie sich
sicher vorstellen können die bücher zu
transportieren dafür zu sorgen dass sie
sicher und verschlossen waren
sicherzustellen dass die bücher
niemandem in die hände fielen bevor sie
in jedermanns hände gelangten die
verkaufszahlen jedes einzelnen buches
stiegen exponentiell an die erste
auflagen wurden viel viel größer die
einzige dunkle wolke die einen schatten
auf das wachsende phänomen warf waren
proteste konservativer religiöser
gruppen die in den mystischen
geschichten das böse sein sie
beschuldigten rowling hexerei und
okkultismus zu fördern und verbrannten
ihre bücher
[Musik]
auch wenn harry potter gerade die welt
im sturm erobert hat swiss text keine
fiktion und keine fantasie hexerei ist
real der teufel ist real
die leute der meinung sind dass hexerei
in kinderbüchern person nichts zu suchen
hat dann ist die debatte wirklich
sinnlos denn viele klassische
kinderbücher würden aus den bibliotheks
regalen verschwinden wie der zauberer
von oz
selbst kardinal joseph ratzinger jetzt
papst benedikt der sechzehnte hatte
seine eigenen vorbehalte und die
amerikanische bibliotheks vereinigung
führte rowlings buch als den am meisten
angefochtenen text in den vereinigten
staaten an
dieser gegenwind hatte allerdings keinen
einfluss auf die verkaufszahlen die
anhaltende vorherrschaft von harry
potter auf der bestsellerliste der new
york times zwang die zeitung schließlich
dazu eine eigene kategorie für
kinderbücher einzuführen ich bin mir
sicher dass unsere konkurrenten
glücklich darüber waren dass sie wieder
mehr plätze auf der bestsellerliste für
sich beanspruchen können denn wir hätten
wahrscheinlich mit den ersten fünf
büchern die top-5 dominiert sei sogar
die hörbuch verkäufe brachen rekorde und
verzauberten die fans wie erzähler dem
dale nach einer live lesungen new york
fest stellte
carlo vor handelt 400 kinder und mütter
waren da und ein kind schrie plötzlich
auf du hast einen satz ausgelassen als
ob es der größte fehler wäre und die
mutter sagte bitte entschuldigen sie ihn
aber er hat das ganze buch auswendig
gelernt und aus dem publikum hörte ich
andere kleine stimmen sagen ich auch ich
auch sauer frei
internationale vertriebe schnappten sich
die rechte zur übersetzung der bücher
und terry porter wurde zu einer
weltweiten sensation
[Musik]
die nachfrage wurde so groß dass für die
marke harry potter die gefahr bestand
außer kontrolle zu geraten
wir hatten supermärkte lebensmittelläden
tankstellen und andere einzelhändler die
plötzlich harry potter bücher haben
wollten um den umsatz anzukurbeln als
lockvogel angebot für ihr geschäft
rowling lehnte hunderte von lizenz
angeboten von sony microsoft und boeing
ab blieb aber ihrer vision treu wie sie
hier in sexy - erzählte als sich die
männer die leute sehen können was für
angebote ich bekommen habe um harry in
werbung und jeder menge lächerlicher
dinge nutzen zu dürfen ich habe
ausnahmslos
aber es gab ein angebot aus hollywood
das sie nicht ablehnen konnte und ein
filmstudio war dabei herauszufinden dass
harry potter wahre wunder bewirken
könnte ich arbeitete für eine neue
produktionsfirma von david hammond jetzt
zu mir sagte nun ich las einen
zeitungsartikel in dem stand dass jemand
das erste buch einer siebenteiligen
serie über einen kleinen jungen
geschrieben hatte der auf ein internat
geht und entdeckt dass er ein zauberer
ist als ich mich also mit ihrem agenten
traf und versuchte ihn davon zu
überzeugen uns das buch zu verkaufen
traten wir als warner brothers auf horde
garantien ist präsident des kino
resource von hollywood.com
[Musik]
ich glaube für warner brothers war es
eine mission das harry potter franchise
zu bekommen ich meine warner brothers
hatte großen erfolg mit dem batman
franchise mit dem matrix franchise und
ich glaube sie waren fest entschlossen
ist zu schaffen und ich glaube deshalb
haben sie den rohling so viel spielraum
gegeben dass ihre kontrolle über diesen
prozess und über die filmreihe angeht
unser erstes treffen mit jockey rowling
fand beim mittagessen statt david hale
und ich hatten ihr ein wenig darüber
erzählt was wir mit dem film machen
wollten und sie setzte sich mit uns
zusammen wir versuchten verzweifelt so
beeindruckend sie brauchte uns natürlich
nicht zu beeindrucken denn das hatte sie
bereits getan
rowling hat angeblich zwei millionen
dollar von warner was für die rechte an
den ersten vier filmen erhalten
es gibt nicht viele autorinnen und
autoren die immer wieder bücher einer
serie heraus bringen die sich alle am
ersten tag 10 12 15 millionen mal
verkaufen das gab ja eine menge einfluss
so konnte sie verlangen dass der film in
großbritannien mit einer rein britischen
besetzung gedreht wird und dass sie
sowohl bei der auswahl der schauspieler
als auch der regisseur ein wort
mitzureden hatte
top regisseure buhlten um zutritt zu
rowlings imaginäre welt nun ich weiß
dass man an steven spielberg herantrat
um beim ersten harry potter film regie
zu führen er wollte ihn eigentlich als
animationsfilm machen aber das kam nicht
zustande und so sprang chris columbus
ein produzent david heyman stellte die
handverlesene besetzung in einem ordner
brothers video vor
chris wahl von drei wunderbaren
britischen schauspielern für die
hauptrollen zeigt wie gut er den geist
dieser bücher versteht und ich glaube
ihr wichtigstes anliegen bei der
verfilmung ihrer vision wahr dass wir
den büchern treu bleiben ich glaube sie
hatte wirklich unglaublich hart daran
gearbeitet charaktere in einer
geschichte zu erschaffen an die sie
glaubt und sie wollte nicht dass das
zerhackt und falsch interpretiert wird
die größte herausforderung dabei
rowlings vision auf die leinwand zu
kriegen bestand darin dass zu dem
zeitpunkt als wir filmten bereits jeder
das buch gelesen hatte
hätten sie sich das jemals erträumen
können nicht in einer million jahren das
war das letzte was ich erwartet hatte
der erste harry-potter-film kam im
november 2001 in die kinos wieder einmal
bewirkte der zauber junge wunder der
film brach alle rekorde mit
90,3 millionen eingespielten dollar war
es das erfolgreichste
eröffnungswochenende des jahres der film
spielte anschließend 317 millionen
dollar ein und war damit der größte ein
spiel erfolg an den heimischen
kinokassen im jahr 2001 rowling behielt
nicht nur die kreative kontrolle sondern
handelte auch einen unbekannten
prozentsatz der film und lizenz gewinne
aus viel wichtiger ist aber dass sie mit
dem endprodukt zufrieden war
ich glaube als ich ihre reaktion auf die
fertigen filme sah habe ich gedacht wir
haben es geschafft es ist alles in
ordnung wir haben sie nicht im stich
gelassen
2001 war auch das jahr in dem joanne
rowling ihren zweiten mann dr michael
mary heiratete
und die harry potter filme sind
weiterhin ein kassenschlager
jeder harry-potter-film stieg zum start
auf platz eins der kinocharts die
filmreihe hat einen perfekten
eröffnungswochenende rekord aufgestellt
wir reden hier über ein jahrzehnt wir
reden über sieben filme
[Musik]
die ertragskraft vor das
einspielergebnis der sieben harry potter
filme ohne den zweiten teil von die
heiligtümer des todes liegt bei 6,4
milliarden dollar da sind heimvideos
fanartikel jegliche art von soundtracks
und alles andere noch nicht einmal mit
eingerechnet es ist das größte film
franchises aller zeiten
[Musik]
hält auch einen anteil an den verkäufen
der harry potter spielzeuge von mattel
und ihr fanartikel imperium expandiert
weiter
denn es ist schwer etwas zu finden das
nicht irgendwann einmal mit einem harry
potter bild versehen war es in der
gaming spielzeug oder sogar
bekleidungsbranche das ist ein enormer
erfolg
2010 bekam harry potter seinen eigenen
themenpark in den universal studios in
orlando der den namen the wizarding
world of harry potter trägt
und wieder einmal drückte rowling allem
ihren persönlichen stempel auf vom
schnee auf dem dach bis zum geschmack
des butterbier sie haben wirklich alle
zutaten eingetütet sind nach edinburgh
gefahren haben es hergestellt und dass
ihr präsentiert das da das ist
butterbier
sie hat zwei weitere kinder bekommen und
lebt jetzt auf einem pastoralen landgut
in nord schottland
und fünf jahre nach dem letzten potter
buch veröffentlicht die rolling einen
neuen roman für erwachsene
ich bin von drachen und einhörnern und
all dem spaß der mit dem schreiben
dieser dinge verbunden ist zu einem buch
übergegangen das sehr persönlich ist und
viel von meiner realität ausdrückt
das buch mit dem titel ein plötzlicher
todesfall wirkte nicht in gleichen
zauber auf kritiker wurde aber trotzdem
zur nummer eins auf den bestsellerlisten
rowling hat erfolg in der literarischen
welt neu definiert für netto vermögen
wird auf fast eine milliarde dollar
geschätzt womit sie zu den reichsten
frauen der welt gehört
[Musik]
die lpkf sie hat sich zu einer
wunderbaren marke entwickelt was ihre
statur ihre ethik und ihr verhalten
angeht
ihre großzügigkeit erstreckt sich auch
wohltätigkeitsorganisationen zur
unterstützung von kindern
alleinerziehender eltern armen menschen
und die multiple sklerose forschung
17 jahre lang hat rowling harry potter
gelebt und geordnet ihre geschichte war
ähnlich wie seine von der überwindung
schreckliche herausforderungen auf dem
weg zur außergewöhnlichen erfolg geprägt
wie sie 2008 der harvard abschlussklasse
erzählte zu wissen dass man aus
rückschlägen weise und stärker
hervorgegangen ist bedeutet dass man
sich seiner fähigkeit zu überleben immer
sicher sein kann man wird sich selbst
oder die stärke seiner beziehung als
dann wirklich kennen wenn beides durch
widrigkeiten auf die probe gestellt
wurde ein solches wissen ist ein wahres
geschenk denn es war schmerzhaft herum
und es war mehr wert als jede
qualifikation die ich jemals erworben
habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]